في تركيا وقبل يومين من بدء التصويت على
الجوله الثانيه من الانتخابات التركيه رفع
كمال
شكوى ضد منافسه الرئيس التركي اردوغان بعد
بث مقطع فيديو يربط الاول بحزب العمال
الكردستاني مطالبا اياها بنحو 47 الف يورو
كتعويض هذا وكان اردوغان قد بث خلال تجمع
كبير في اسطنبول مقطع فيديو قصير يظهر على
حد قوله كالتشار اوغلو يسير يدا بيد مع
حزب العمال الكردستاني المنظمه التي
تصنفها انقره على انها ارهابيه وبالرغم من
انه اعترف بان الفيديو مفبرك وكرر هنا
الرئيس التركي الاتهام المباشر لخصمه بانه
متحالف مع منظمه حزب العمال الكردستاني
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات